there are definitely elements in Shazam
that kids might simply blow right past
on their way to experiencing the
superhero spectacle in the heart of the
family story while adult superhero fans
are still turning those ideas over in
their heads here's some stuff in Shazam
that you might only notice if you're an
adult
Shazam takes place in the same world as
Man of Steel Justice League and the
other recent DC movies which means
Batman Superman Wonder Woman and Aquaman
exist alongside Billy Batson and Freddy
Freeman
that's probably why Freddy is absolutely
obsessed with these super people but it
seems he's not the only one as received
from Freddy's collection of memorabilia
and a chase scene to a toy store this
world has reacted to superheroes in the
same way that ours has merchandising
merchandising merchandising where their
real buddy from the movie is made yes
Batman and Superman are real but they
have their own action figures replicas
weaponry and even t-shirts just like we
have so how exactly does that work in
the world of the film those heroes all
have secret identities so did those
companies get permission to use their
likenesses do the heroes just ignore
it's Bruce Wayne might not need any of
the royalties from his action figures
but you know Aquaman would absolutely
take a check for his t-shirt sales the
film begins in 1974 when a young
fattiest Savannah is brought before the
wizard Shazam only to be told he's not
worthy because he was tempted by the
seven deadly sins
as soon as Savannah leaves Shazam sends
out a summoning spell to find a champion
as quickly as possible which takes about
forty five years when Shazam meets Billy
he explains that they chose a champion
once who portrayed them someone DC fans
will recognize as Black Adam and that
he's been looking for a replacement ever
since
and yet the wizard has gone through
dozens of potential champions only to
wind up telling them all they're not
worthy so what took so long
there are obviously heroes in the world
and good and decent people willing to do
things like for example open up their
home to foster kids it's implied that
Billy was something of a compromise
because the wizard was running out of
time but he probably could have
compromised a little sooner especially
when you consider that later in the
movie Billy starts handing out powers to
his foster siblings for a guy facing a
ticking clock that ran from ancient
Egypt until 2019 he really put things
off until the last possible moment and
he
had to settle for a teenager who charges
for selfies people typically like give
me a little money you know Billy Batson
is a 14 year old boy when we meet him
and when a wizard gives him the ability
to transform into a full-grown man
simply by saying a magic word his brain
definitely stays 14 Billy's more than
happy to use his newfound stature to do
some very adult things including buying
beer which he winds up hating and even
going to a strip club where he quickly
unloads all of his cash we're gonna need
more money
why here inflate five minutes to do a
very convincing this is generally pretty
understandable and amusing behavior that
most 14-year olds would attempt in some
form if they thought they could get away
with it but it also makes us wonder how
far Billy would have gone if the
supervillain threat hadn't grabbed his
attention
would he have tried to buy hard liquor
gotten a driver's license applied for a
low-interest home loan would he have
even moved on from strip clubs - well do
we have to say it the bill never takes
this any further for a good reason
but it definitely raises the question
especially for the people in the
audience who remember what it was like
to be 14 themselves at the climax of the
movie after learning what it means to be
a hero
Billy shares his power with his siblings
to create a whole family of lightning
powered heroes I don't believe in
violent but I think we should kick this
guy's butt like really hard that means
that all of Billy's foster siblings will
have access to the rock of eternity
where the seven deadly sins are
reimprisonment that Billy's first
impulses hit everything from lust to
gluttony how do we know that one of the
younger kids won't one day be tempted by
their power sounds like things were
getting more than a little desperate if
the wizard was willing to take that
chance
the act of selflessness that gets Billy
on the Wizards radar in the first place
comes when to bullies start beating up
Freddy Freeman
after hitting him with their truck they
only clip him and it's not clear if they
meant to or if it was just a happy
accident but that's the first thing we
see them do and we never really learn
anything else about them all of the
adults out there who have been through
high school themselves are definitely
aware that sometimes kids can be jerks
for no good reason and get away with it
but still constantly picking on a
disabled classmate to the point of
running him over with a truck even the
crappiest school would have a pretty big
problem with that the film never shows
us anything that hints at their
motivation so if that's just how they
are
maybe they should be in prison instead
of high school though shazam is also
simply the name of the wizard in the
film we are given a more detailed reason
why Billy needs to say that exact word
it's an acrostic and by saying it the
champion is imbued with the wisdom of
Solomon the strength of Hercules the
endurance of Atlas the power of Zeus the
courage of Achilles and the speed of
mercury throughout the course of the
film we see Billy ultimately using all
of these abilities except one the wisdom
of Solomon how do you know my name
how do I know your name one of my
superpowers is a name guessing Billy
still a teenage boy so we can't expect
that wisdom to be an action all the time
well the wizard explains he will possess
this wisdom and then we never really see
it you think he could have at least put
it to good use to ace a math test or
something the film does a good job of
contrasting Billy's superhero abilities
with his teenage fallow ability man
maybe we'll get to see a little more of
that problem-solving in future films
when the minds controlling worm showing
up he'll probably need it check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorites topper coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]